ANDY: Hey, Austin.
Today we have an
author, magician,
host of "Scam School,"
the only show dedicated
to social engineering at
the bar and on the street,
and now "Hacking the System"
on the National Geographic
Channel.
Let's give a big,
warm Google awesome
welcome to Brian Brushwood.
[AUDIENCE  CHEERS]
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: All right!
Wow!
What a response!
Howdy guys, my name
is Brian Brushwood.
Real quick, hands in
the air if any of you
guys have seen any of the
projects that I've done.
OK, great.
This is great.
Five years ago when somebody
asked who I was and what I did,
it was very, very simple.
My job is I am a
touring full-time stage
performer who dabbles on
the internet here and there.
Things have changed over
the last half decade.
Nowadays I host a show
on National Geographic.
You know, "Scam Schools," one
of the top 1,000 most subscribed
channels on all of YouTube.
But I wanted to talk about
where everything began.
And where it began
was right here.
This is a photo of me
and the Magician Teller
from Penn and Teller, standing
on the exact spot where
20 years before I originally
started street performing.
At the age of 19,
20 years old, I
had a vague sense that I wanted
to be like Penn and Teller.
I wanted to be like
Harry Anderson.
I wanted to be a travelling,
touring stage performer.
But no sense of
how to get there.
And so instead I
met Penn and Teller
after one of their shows.
They're very approachable.
I encourage you to
watch their show
and go up and meet
with them afterwards.
And I made the joke
to Teller, I said hey,
you know sign this card.
Make it out to my bastard son.
And he thought that
was funny enough
that we struck up a
brief conversation,
and I found out
later that I had been
added on to his email list.
And so I said, oh my gosh I
have Teller's email address.
Of course, this is the mid
'90s and the very novelty
of the e-mail was exciting.
And four times I started to
write a letter to my hero,
and I couldn't figure
out how to begin.
I didn't want to sound
like just another fan.
I assumed that he gets emails
like this all the time.
I wanted to stand out.
I wanted to get real
advice from him.
And then one day, in
a fit of random rage,
I wrote this, with the
subject heading of "Fury."
And I wrote a letter
to Teller talking
about how angry I was at him.
Not for being brilliant.
Not for being original.
Not for being extraordinary.
But because he got there first.
And I realized that because he
got there first, I could never
be the kind of
magician I wanted to be
without looking like a shabby
Penn and Teller knockoff.
One of the bits of advice that
I'd read from them in a article
in I want to say "Genii
Magazinee," they say
don't, when you are
writing your material,
don't be inspired by
something you love.
If you are inspired by
something that you love,
the best you will be is
a pale, shabby imitation
of whatever that thing is.
So instead, be inspired
by what you hate.
Go see a bunch of
crappy magic shows.
Figure out exactly what
you hate about all of them
and then be the exact opposite.
Now you are something truly
original and extraordinary,
and you made your own
space in the universe.
So I wrote him, I don't know
just to give him a hard time.
And writing the
email was cathartic.
I felt this weight off.
I was like, whoa, look at me.
I feel like I
expressed by my rage.
I'm 19.
And the next morning,
to my utter surprise,
Teller wrote a four and
half page essay in response
on the nature of creativity.
By the way, just look at
Brian Brushwood Teller letter
if you want to read
the entire thing.
And in it he talks about--
there's one line that
really sticks out in my mind.
He says, take your best
stab and keep on stabbing.
If it's in you it's
going to come out.
And what I took
away from that is
that I needed to put
myself in a position
to discover what was inside me.
And what I discovered is
that street performing seemed
like a good place to begin.
It's something that
nobody could tell you no.
The worst case
scenario is people
turn around and walk away.
And if you're really lucky,
you get $50 of beer money
by the end of the night.
Unfortunately,
here in Austin they
don't have an established
hierarchy or permitting
system for street performing,
or they didn't at the time.
And so I actually noticed
that this souvenir
shop on Sixth street has
a two foot wide strip.
It used to be a
jewelry shop that
would close in the evenings.
And I figured out that if I
was on the public sidewalk,
I was illegally performing
without a permit.
But if I was on this two foot
strip, I was only trespassing.
And if I was only
trespassing, then
they could only chase me off
if it was the private property
owners, or at least
that's what I told myself.
And over this time, I
learned a bit about-- eh--
when you put yourself
out there, when
you try to share what's in
your heart, when you try
to have some kind
of art out there,
turns out you're going to deal
with people who don't like it.
And if there's one thing
I want you to take away
from the opening
remarks here is that you
should love your trolls.
I started off not
loving my trolls.
I learned when I was
street performing
that the way you get
someone to shut the hell up
is shine just enough
spotlight on them that they
feel a fraction of the fear
that I feel on stage performing.
I realized that if
I wanted to keep
going with my narrative,
what I needed to do
was turn the entire rest of
the audience against that one
person.
And you learn zingers.
In many ways, doing any
kind of variety performer
is like living the life
of "Groundhog Day."
You do the same show.
It doesn't matter where you
are, what situation you're in,
for that one hour, it's
always the same strict stage.
It's always the same audience.
It's always the same situations.
Whenever you see a seasoned
variety performer have
a quick zinger, it
is not because they
are very quick on their feet.
The reason was, three years
ago someone heckled him
with the exact same line,
and four days afterwards, he
was like, son of a bitch!
That's what I should've said!
And he filed it away, right?
And it's very comforting.
It's very soothing
to have this idea
that no matter how
bad one show goes,
you know that down the
road you can try again.
So after performing on the
street for a little bit,
I moved indoors, and
I started performing
at a little venue called
the Electric Lounge where
I would do the same 15 minute
set and then pass the hat.
And I started touring
to colleges nationwide.
And I had a moment-- some
lessons come to you early on.
You have an idea for what
kind of outrageous stunt
you want to pull.
And then other things
take longer to realize.
And in this case, I
was at Davis and Elkins
college in West
Virginia, and I did not
connect with that audience.
My show was meant to be a
sarcastic, almost middle finger
parody of, what at the
time was the bedazzled,
sequined-wearing, fans blowing
your David Copperfield hair
kind of magic show.
And it turns out that the
exact thing I was mocking
was what that crowd
really wanted to see.
And at the end of the show, I
walked off stage and somebody
threw fruit at my stage.
I did not know that
this was a real thing.
I walk off, and all of a
sudden there's just a slam,
and I turn around
just in time to see
orange juice you know sliming
down over one of my props.
And it occurred to
me, I was like, why
is it that I'm not connecting
with this audience?
And then this happened.
This is a statement that I never
thought I was going to make.
Later, the next year, I toured
with Brooks and Dunn, Rascal
Flatts, and Brad Paisley is a
thing that actually happened.
And they set up something
called the Neon Circus Stage.
It was like a midway, and I
would do my punk rock magic.
I would shove tubes up my
nose, pull it out my mouth,
I would hammer a 4 and
1/2 inch nail in my nose
and have blood and
guts everywhere.
But one of the best things
that came out of all this
was a-- we had our own tour bus.
It was amazing.
That's me giving the
middle finger, sorry.
Straight jacket escape.
This guy right here.
His name is Dennis Rogers.
And he, at the time I
thought was so, so, so wrong.
Dennis Rogers is a
former world champion arm
wrestler who has
a supreme gift, he
has unbelievably
dense muscle tissue.
If you touch his forearm,
it is like touching a brick.
His act consists of stuff
like taking a frying pan
and rolling it up like
he's rolling a newspaper.
He'll take a wrench,
you know, that you'll
do your best to
even make a dent in,
and he just bends it
like it's nothing.
He bends iron spikes.
He is legitimately,
phenomenally gifted in strength.
And yet I saw him
in this environment,
where you get a bunch
of people-- that's
the nice thing about street
performing or midway performing
is that it's the most
artistically pure venue I
can think of.
Because nobody's
there to see you.
Nobody showed up
because you're there.
You have to earn the respect to
get people to stop and watch.
And there was one show
that it drove me nuts,
because I'm watching
Dennis Rogers, who
again is legitimately the best
in breed with what he does.
And I watch him
responding, giving power
to these trolls, these hecklers.
There's three or four of these
frat boy douchebags sitting
there with their red Solo cups
shouting out that this is fake,
or that's rigged, or whatever.
And to me, as the jaded, bitter
street performer, I'm like,
look you mock them, turn
the audience against them,
look them in the
eye, say shut up,
and then you get
on with your show.
And instead, what
I watched Dennis
do was give them all the power.
He came up afterward-- he did
his whole show twice, once
on stage and again
one-on-one for them, handing
over the individual wrenches.
Well, here go ahead and
check out the wrench.
Try to bend it.
And then [SOUND EFFECT].
Oh, sure, yeah, I'll be
happy to arm wrestle you.
By the way, I'm genuinely a
world champion arm wrestler.
And at the time, I
was so disappointed
because I felt like, ah,
Dennis don't you get it?
They're cattle.
They need to be moved
to the slaughter chutes.
You need to own
this performance.
You're better than that.
And it turns out that
I was completely wrong,
and Dennis is 100% right.
Because, after touring for
15 years with the stage show,
and getting pretty
good at it, it
turns out that all
the rules changed once
we launched "Scam School."
We launched "Scam
School" back in 2008.
And I thought, at the
time, that "Scam School"
would be a good first practice
round before I got a real TV
show, whatever that means.
I thought that a simple show
about bar tricks and scams
would be popular enough.
And this will fold, like all
startups are going to fold,
and who cares?
And it turns out that here we
are seven, eight years later
And one and a quarter
million subscribers.
Specifically, when "Scam School"
launched, for the first time
I got a new kind of heckler.
I encountered the troll.
This was, by the way,
all of the comments
I grabbed-- I don't know if
you can read any of these,
but I grabbed all of
these this morning.
And they're all taking a dump
on my hairstyle at the time.
Whatever.
All of a sudden I
realized the rules
that worked in a live
stage performance
don't work for trolls.
You can't shine a
spotlight on them
because that's all
they want in the world.
You can't turn the
audience against them
because they don't care
what everyone else says.
They are doing it
for the sheer joy of,
in their mind speaking
truth to power, or whatever.
And I went through a number of
phases in dealing with trolls.
There was times I was
defensive, I was argumentative.
For a good year my
reply to everyone
was just to respond with
a link to the Big Lebowski
with The Dude
saying, "Yeah, well,
that's just your opinion, man."
But ultimately, I found
myself in the position
that nowadays, when I respond,
if there's a pat answer,
it's with an emoticon,
an Emoji saying, "Hugs.
Come on over.
Hey, check this out.
You'll find out I'm an OK guy."
And that seems to be the
most successful thing.
Specifically, and
again, I don't know why,
but it seems like taking
that Dennis Rogers'
approach of respecting the
troll somehow pivots them.
It flips them over.
And I think about
it in terms-- there
was a speaker in
the college market,
and I wish I could
remember his name.
But he told me Bruce
Lee never, ever
tried to match force with force.
When a punch was coming,
he never grabbed it.
He would always divert
it off to the side.
And that's what you
get with trolls.
You don't worry about
when the wind is blowing
the wrong direction,
if you're trying
to get across the Atlantic.
You worry when there is no wind.
And the same energy that makes
trolls passionate to just
scream, "I hate your hair!"
is the exact same thing that
by being recognised and
listen to it can be pivoted
into making them one
of your biggest fans.
And that is exactly what
happened with Dennis Rogers
and those fraternity boys.
And specifically-- so
one of the things that
happened when I started
street performing is--
the whole reason
I got started was
because I knew that I
did not have the ability,
I did not have the experience
to be clever on the fly,
to wrap people in,
to build a crowd,
to establish a connection.
And so I needed a safe place
to be bad for me to be good.
And the street was
perfect for that.
I realized that when
"Scam School" launched,
I didn't have the tools.
I don't know how to deal
with this new type of trolls.
And I wanted a passionate
fun-run community.
And there was no way I was going
to get that five minutes once
a week in a one
way conversation.
So I turned on a
web camera, and I
did something I
called the "BB Live
Show," for Brian Brushwood.
B.B. That's my initials.
And it was genuinely awful.
I go back, and I look at
it now, and it's miserable.
It's awkward.
I cringe.
I'm fidgety.
I don't have anything to say.
It goes nowhere.
And yet it was a
safe place to be bad.
Because I could be bad
for 80 people at a time.
That's the great thing
about the internet.
One of two things happens.
If you're spectacularly bad,
and you get famous for it,
in which case, win.
Or you're boring, in
which case nobody watches.
In which case, win.
Because you've got
that experience.
You've got that training.
Nowadays, that
community has become
this fully self-sustained
community at diamondclub.tv.
We've got five different
channels that are running.
People are providing their
own gameplay content.
There is a living chat room
that's alive at all times.
And all of this began because
I found a safe place to be bad.
So whatever your
artistic endeavor,
I would say find a safe place
to be bad so you can be good.
But also realize that you're
going to have difficulties
along the way.
And in this case, my biggest
difficulty, my biggest,
loudest heckler, the most
miserable day of my life
was on, I believe,
March 2, 2013.
How many of you guys are
familiar with the online forum
4chan?
Hands in the air?
OK They have a bit of a
reputation, those guys.
One day 4chan says, hey,
let's roll some dice
and whoever they
roll up on, let's all
rush that person's
YouTube channel
and accuse that person
of being a pedophile.
Which, I'm not going to
lie, it's kind of brilliant.
Because it's, literally,
it's the perfect box.
You rush in, and you call
somebody a pedophile,
what are they going to say?
No, I love children!
I have children!
Why would you say that?
One of the many sayings
associated with 4chan
is that they do stuff
for the lulz, meaning,
it's not personal.
We don't actually hate you.
We could care less.
We just want to get a
chuckle out of this.
So we'll ruin your life.
And so, sure enough,
that day-- luckily, they
had grabbed screen shots of it.
But apparently they
were like, hey,
whose life should we ruin with
accusations of pedophilia?
Somebody was like, how
about Justin Bieber?
Well, let's roll the dice.
No, it's not going
to be Justin Bieber.
What about this guy?
He does science
demos on YouTube.
Well, let's roll the dice.
No, it won't be him.
And then somebody was
like, what about this guy?
He does magic on the internet.
[SOUND EFFECT] We have a winner!
And I got a-- yeah, we'll do
this-- I got a tweet saying,
heads up, 4chan raid incoming.
And I went and checked
out our most recent video,
and there was a bit of
a traffic spike on it.
And all of it being nothing but
everything you would imagine.
Like, oh my gosh,
you can't believe
what this guy did to that girl.
I can't believe this.
Oh, I used to respect this guy!
I hope he rots in hell!
And you could see that it
was very clearly coordinated,
and it was rolling outward.
Because first it was
just the one video.
Then it was the next
video next door.
Then it was my Wikipedia
page getting vandalized.
And luckily, I happen to be
in the middle of a recording
session with my co-host,
Justin Robert Young.
We were recording
a comedy album.
And I was like, what do you do?
This is the perfect play.
This is the perfect troll.
There is no response.
And Justin nailed it.
He says, you have to take
the wind out of their sails.
Understand they
hold all the power.
You hold none of it.
The only thing you can
do is make it not fun
for them to continue
going forward.
And so we poked
around a little bit.
We knew that, what does
the internet respond to?
They respond to effort.
They respond to honesty.
They responded directness.
They respond to respect.
And what we ended up
doing-- I hope I'm still
connected to the internet.
I was going to-- let me see
if I can throw this on here.
You guys can not
see that apparently.
There we go.
So, this is an
advertisement that I'm going
to talk over the entire time.
You know what, we did not think
about audio side of things.
I'm going to turn this up, and
hopefully you can pick it up.
And actually, what I'll do is
I'll set this down over here.
So here's what we ended
up putting together.
It was something that
was out of nowhere
with virtually no
preparation, and I
wanted to show respect
and make it not fun.
So this is what we did.
And I will click refresh,
and we will watch another ad.
Oh, oh, oh oh!
And let me back this up.
I don't know if we
can-- do we have audio?
Or you know what?
I'll just lay this.
How about that.
There we go.
Boom.
And.
Look at me.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Oh, hello internet.
Today is a momentous occasion
because after five years
and nearly 300 episodes of
"Scam School" we finally gotten
big enough to attract
the attention of 4chan!
That's right 4chan!
That loveable group of
rapscallions who stir up
trouble on the internet.
And today I was the lucky
lottery winner of a honest
to goodness /b pedo-bomb, that's
where everyone gets together--
Give me my reward.
I won it fair and square.
There you go.
Boom.
That's a /b champion,
right there.
So they come in, and then
everyone calls you a pedophile.
But here's the important thing,
and I mean this sincerely,
thank you, because we need
to views very, very badly.
Big, big fan.
The views, great.
Pedophiles comments
not so great.
But the views I'm OK with.
I want to thank 4chan
for considering me.
I want to chat realm for marking
all those comments as spam.
Feel free to keep on doing that.
But most importantly, and
I mean this to you, 4chan,
I need to know, sincerely.
Like, were you able to figure
out the puzzle challenge?
Because I thought
it was pretty good.
Like the first one
was pretty easy.
It was in "The Simpsons."
But the second one,
I thought that one
would have gotten you for sure.
Oh, subscribe.
And comment.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: All
right so, I don't
know if you could see the
doe-eyed terror in my face.
But that was definitely
absolutely terrifying.
Here's what I did not expect
to have come out of that.
The main things I
wanted to do were
to let our fans know that there
was a thing happening, to tell
the truth about what
it is, but most of all
to love, honestly
love and show respect,
for the people as
they're shouting
these horrible things at me.
And it seemed to work.
And again, that's not
an invitation for anyone
to start another one of these.
But I guess that's all
I really wanted to say.
So let's pull
everything out and see
if you guys have any questions.
I know we're about,
what, 30 minutes in here?
Yeah.
You guys, let's open everything
up for Q&A. Love your trolls,
is all I'm trying to say.
Who's got questions?
AUDIENCE: So this is
what you do full time?
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: Yeah, well,
I mean that's the funny part.
What is full time?
You know, is it the
stage performing?
At some point touring, doing
a 150 college shows a year
became a day job for me.
And doing internet
stuff in the evening
became the side project for fun.
And then all of a sudden,
you pick up a TV show,
and all of the sudden that
becomes your new day job.
But I guess the
short answer is yes.
AUDIENCE: So how many YouTube
videos per week or per month
do you have to
create in order to--?
BRIAN BUSHWOOD:
Keep the lights on?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: Yeah.
Well, it depends.
The nice thing about
YouTube is that it's
a platform that allows
you to very, very cheaply
create content.
And if you're splitting
the paycheck one way,
there's not a whole lot
that you need to do.
You just press record,
and you talk into mic.
"Scam School" is fairly
elaborately produced.
So we need a sound guy.
We need a couple of editors.
Shooters.
So it becomes more expensive.
Right now we've settled
in with "Scam School"
being regular
content once a week,
and we have two spin off
shows behind the Scam
and "Scam School" remix
that along with partnerships
for promotions, we're able to
get enough to keep like a three
man team sustained.
Where it's worth it to
invest the time to do it.
I don't know if that
answers your question.
But we're finally
to a point where
the pie is big
enough that we can
support three people full time.
And that ended up being
three videos per week,
and we're hoping to expand
even more from there.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: How about what--
are there any new platforms,
after YouTube Launch, that you
think are good places to be bad
so that you can become good?
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: Yeah.
Nowadays, I would say Periscope
is a fantastic-- or Meerkat.
Basically, in many ways,
what we're seeing right now
is a reboot of what we saw
in the live stream space
exactly six years ago.
It used to be that
Ustream and Justin.tv were
the big, easy ways to jump in.
And nowadays, that's
kind of come full circle,
and nowadays you have
it on your phone.
And so it's amazing
what happens-- like,
right now, I'm
looking at you guys.
You're looking at me.
This is a very real moment.
I'm 100% dialed in and present.
It's amazing what
happens when you
watch that viewer count
rise up in front of you
because you can
picture the room.
And it's like, I
know what it looks
like to perform for 30 to 40
people at a time in a room.
And when whenever I see
currently watching 30 to 40,
I picture exactly that room.
And I picture trying to hold
everybody's interest exactly
that hard.
Puts you in a totally
different head space.
So I would say, definitely,
a safe place to be bad.
Especially because
Meerkat, Periscope only
gets saved if you
want to be saved.
And that's a precious and
rare commodity nowadays.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: After the four
and half page response
from Teller, did you
ever have an opportunity
to get into another
conversation with him?
Like what was that response?
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: Yeah.
As a matter of fact, was
astonishing because, like I
said, just writing the
letter meant a lot to me.
But instead, you get this
extraordinary journey
about how-- one of
the things he says
in there is at the heart of
all great magic is surprise.
And the way he phrased
it was beautiful.
He said, put two and
two in front of me,
convince me it's five, then
reveal the truth, four,
and blow me away.
It ended up kicking
off a correspondence.
Every time I had a new routine,
I would record VHS tapes,
back in the day,
and mail them over.
And I was always astonished that
he took the time to watch them,
and he gave
thoughtful responses.
As a matter of fact, I recently
was on Penn and Teller's show,
"Fool Us" and a bunch of
people were a little bit
dis-- I would say, some
fans were disappointed
because they wanted me to try
harder to fool Penn and Teller.
And what I couldn't
really say to most of them
was that-- Fool Us
Brian Brushwood.
Here we go.
What I couldn't
say is that I don't
think there's a single
stage act in my entire show
that Teller hasn't had a
personal hand in helping
me write.
Whether it's giving
feedback or giving
an interpretation or an
unusual theatrical spin on.
So it occurred to
me that if I was not
going to fool Penn and Teller--
because you can't fool dad
when he taught you everything
you know-- what I was going
to do was play to the audience
and instead figure out
how to find moments of-- to step
outside the rules for any given
performance.
So in this case, what I did
was we took a bill from the guy
from the audience.
We chopped it up.
And again, this is
not rocket science
from a magic perspective.
But what I love
about this routine
is that I actually make an
individual from the audience
eat the burnt ashes of his
own selected signed bill.
And there is no trick.
It is all designed to take
advantage of social pressure.
The first thing I say
is, I need someone
from the audience who's willing
to do absolutely anything.
And whoever stands up and goes,
whoop, then it's like you,
get on up here.
And then, we have
him select the bill.
We burn it up.
And then I chop
it up and I mix it
with his choice, either
applesauce or pudding.
So he now has a
small investment.
And as I'm mixing,
there's this great moment
that I say, hey, do me a favor.
Just taste it.
Again, I'm not asking
him to do anything crazy.
I say, just taste this.
So now he's tasted
it, and he's on stage
and all of a sudden, that's
when it's like checkmate.
Then I'm like, do me a favor.
Just polish this off.
Something amazing
is going to happen.
The faster you eat, the
louder they're going to clap.
Watch.
And then all of a sudden,
the audience is cheering,
and he realizes that there's
no getting out of this.
And he actually does it.
And then we go on
to pull them apart.
But again, the
whole reason that I
wanted to do this particular
routine was not to fool.
People think that the power
in magic is in the mystery
or in the gap of me knowing
how it's done and you not.
That could not be farther
from the truth, in my opinion.
There is no mystery when
we watch a concert pianist.
We know exactly
what's happening.
They press the key a hammer
strikes a wire that's
tuned to a frequency.
And he just does all of it in
an exquisitely beautiful, heart
wrenching, tear
inducing symphony.
Right?
Magic is the same thing.
If anybody loved magic
as much as I love magic,
and they knew just
as much as I did,
then all that
means is that magic
would become the number
one art on the planet
and the most popular
thing for everyone to do.
I think I may have
talked a little bit
around your question.
But I hope I got--
the answer is yes.
Teller and I have had
an exquisite journey
over these years.
This correspondence
has been amazing,
and I hope to get to
share more of that stuff.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I'll do
one on "Scam School."
Which episode would you say was
the one you're most proud of?
And which one would you say
was the most fun to make?
Maybe that's the same one.
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: No, they're
definitely not the same one.
In fact, the one I'm most
proud of was in every way
the most miserable one to make.
But I'm most proud
of it because it
got performed on the
International Space Station
by video game legend
Richard Garriott, a.k.a.
Lord British.
Turns out Richard Garriott
lives here in Austin.
As a kid, I was a tremendous
fan of his Ultima series.
You know, "Ultima III:
Exodus," playing it
when I was in third grade.
And I had an idea
for a magic routine
that you could use YouTube
as a method for the trick.
So what we did was we recorded
104 different versions
of a fake interview on YouTube.
And you guys can
still look this up.
In fact, we should probably
do a re-mix episode on it.
But what happens is you
say to someone like,
hey, I don't know if you
believe in mind control,
not like this crazy
like voodoo stuff.
In fact, we'll do it with you.
What's your name?
Suzie, Suzie.
OK.
I don't believe in ESP or
mind-reading and stuff,
but I do believe
that there's ways
to kind of psychologically nudge
people in the right direction.
And I was watching this show.
There was this interview.
There is this crazy
life coach doctor expert
who said that he
could cause someone
to think of a playing
card by reciting
a couple of lines of poetry.
Let me give this a try.
The poetry was, "The woods
are lovely, dark, and deep,
but I have promises to keep and
miles to go before I sleep."
What playing card are you
thinking of right now?
AUDIENCE: Eight of clubs.
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: Shut up.
Did you see the interview?
Pinky promise?
OK, because that's
exactly what the guy says!
Here, I don't want to touch it.
I don't want to do it.
Walk over that computer-- you
don't have to actually do it.
This guy's name was--
he was a life coach.
If you search for Coach
Charles Doubleday.
Here, so you search you go
Coach Charles Doubleday.
And let's see if we can
find the-- oh good, yeah,
no here he is.
Here.
Look.
This is the exact interview
I was talking about.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Welcome back to Scam School.
We are here at the Nomad
Bar in Austin, Texas.
And today we are talking
to Coach Charles Doubleday.
Now before I went to
break, you said something
that kind of blew my mind.
It sounded like you were
describing like-- I mean,
it sound like mind control.
-Actually it is.
Our studies of
neurolinguistic programming
have discovered deep
structures in the human brain
that can be accessed
with linguistic triggers.
We can actually put a
thought into someone's mind.
-Like against their will, yeah?
Do you any examples?
-We would read a
poem by Robert Frost.
"The woods are lovely,
dark, and deep,
and I have promises to keep and
miles to go before I sleep."
Then we would have
them think of a card,
and every time they would
think of the eight of clubs.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN BUSHWOOD: [LAUGHING] So,
one of the beautiful things
was it turns out that Richard
Garriott was a fan of the show,
and he found himself in a
quarantine in I want to say,
Baikonur, Kazahstan.
And he decided like, wow, this
would be the perfect thing
to do from a very
remote connection,
from the International
Space Station,
and he performed it on his dad.
And we have that on there.
Unfortunately, because it
was such a pain in the ass
to edit together 104 versions
because we wanted to make sure
there was a long version
and a short version.
We also had to open up
52 different accounts
for all of the variations
of the expert's name.
But the beautiful thing is that
it's a gift that just lives out
there, all on its own.
So the answer to your
question is the one
I'm most proud of was not at all
the most fun to do, in any way.
Any other questions?
I know that we're a
little bit tight today.
Dude.
Well, if that's it.
ANDY: Well, thanks,
Brian, for coming out.
We really appreciate it.
Yeah, it was great
hearing from you today.
BRIAN BUSHWOOD:
You got it, Andy.
Thanks so much guys.
Appreciate it.